el monte everest tiene ocho mil 848
metros de altura estima la altura del
monte everest al reescribir la como un
número de la forma x por 10 al agen
metros donde xy son números de un solo
dígito lo que hay son números como por
ejemplo siete o cuatro aunque hay nada
de 7.54 hoy y blablabla ok entonces
tenemos que escribir a este número que
es la altura del monte everest de esta
forma que se parece muchísimo a la
anotación científica excepto porque nos
piden que tanto x como ye sean números
de un solo dígito entonces vamos a
empezar por escribir este número en
forma de notación científica para eso
buscamos el primer dígito y queremos
poner un punto a la derecha entonces
tenemos por aquí 8 punto
848 conste que esta comedia no es ningún
punto pero como aquí ya estamos
escribiendo connotación científica este
de aquí ya es un punto ahora el resto de
la anotación científica es multiplique
para encontrar el botón de multiplicar
no vayan a creer que es un como una
equis en realidad si te fijas aquí lo
escribe como una variable equis y eso no
es lo que queremos queremos el simbolito
que es una estrella como ésta aunque en
mi teclado está dos teclas a la derecha
de la p y para ponerlo tengo que
presiona primero la tecla alt
y mientras la sigo presionando poner la
tecla que tiene a la estrellita ahora
aquí me está diciendo que no entiende
qué es lo que acabo de escribir porque
no he terminado de poner la
multiplicación y se pone un poco
quisquilloso a la página entonces a ver
tenemos aquí en nuestro número que es
mayor o igual que 1 y menor que 10 y lo
estamos multiplicando con este símbolo
de estrellita
10 elevado en el símbolo de elevado
también es un poco especial elevado a la
a ver queríamos poner el punto por aquí
por lo que tuvimos que recorrer el punto
1 2 3 lugares entonces tenemos que poner
10 elevado a la 3 y para escribir a este
símbolo en mi teclado yo tengo que poner
igual al cr y la tecla que está al lado
de la ñ pero bueno tú tienes que buscar
en tu teclado qué es lo que tienes que
poner entonces aquí abajo me está
diciendo exactamente qué es lo que la
computadora cree que estoy yo quiero
decir que es 8.848 por 10 a la 3 y si no
si multiplicamos esto por 10 a la 3 y
nos queda 8.848 metros que es la altura
del monte everest
ahora este no es precisamente la
respuesta si queremos la respuesta
necesitamos que x que es este número y
sean números de un solo dígito aunque a
la fecha la tenemos muy bien como un
número de un solo dígito 3 si es un
número de un solo dígito pero
necesitamos que la x que en este caso
estamos diciendo que es 8.848 sea de un
solo dígito ahora el asunto aquí es que
nos están pidiendo que estimemos la
altura no que la pongamos de forma
exacta y para mí la mejor estimación con
un número de un solo dígito de 8.848 es
lo que obtenemos al redondear ok y
redondeamos 8.848 y lo que nos queda es
un 9 entonces la respuesta aquí es 9 por
10 a la 3 que es una buena estimación
con números de un solo dígito de esta
forma
la altura del monte everest entonces
vamos a checar si nuestra respuesta está
bien poniéndole comprobar respuesta y
listo nuestra respuesta fue correcta